before we get started um should i call
you
professor walter or may i call you
richard you please call me richard okay
and i'll tell you something about that
um
my kids they're now not kids anymore
they'll always be my kids but they're
they're grown-up people they went to a
wonderful private school
uh was supposed to say independent
school and
um i loved everything about it but there
was one aspect of it that i didn't
really favor which was they were on a
first
name basis with the the teachers
um and i didn't think that was
appropriate for like elementary school
kids and even for high school kids
uh they're not friends you know with the
teachers the teacher has authority over
them
friendship is a two-way street
among equals and that's not the case
with a
you know ninth grade math teacher or uh
you know a fourth grade
elementary school teacher and her
students um here in our program at ucla
our master fine arts program we are on a
first name basis with our students
and it seems like a contradiction but
there's actually a pedagogical
undergirding for it and it has to do
with the fact that we want to try to
um debauch our own authority
um you can't go to the an agent
or a producer with your screenplay and
say the professor gave me an a on this
you know so we we think by having
everybody on a first name basis
uh reminds the writers in our program
that um it's up to the screenplay that
all that matters is the uh the
screenplay we want to
again put authority in its place
and so it reminds this adult that
they're not really being babied
in some sense well but they are
grown-ups and that you can't uh
rely on an authority the professor like
me to
ultimately to tell you whether the
script is ready or not only you know you
alone can decide that
and you have to take the point is you
have to take the authority
uh authority uh it starts with author
you're the author of
of a work you have to take the authority
for your work every artist has to take
authority for her own creative
expression tiny little way to to make
that point is to be on a first name
basis with us students
also i will say our students are not
little children we are a graduate
program
and even in that context we we tend to
um
tilt towards more mature riders people
who've been out in the world a little
bit it's very unusual for somebody to
come
directly from another program and
undergraduate program into
our program particularly an
undergraduate film
program so uh the people who do get in
there the grown-ups are not little kids
and uh all the more reason to sort of be
on a first name basis
not to diminish our authority i mean we
are who we
are and they are what they are uh that
is to say we are the faculty and they
are the students
but i think it is useful to be on a
first name basis in this regard because
of
for the reasons that i said that it it
reminds the writers that
finally when all is dead in the sun it's
up done it's up to them it's not up to
anybody else but them the writer
you